how do you keep sensitive plot details
secret easy don't give Tom Holland a
script we're joking in fact he's far
from the only actor who spoiled a huge
Blockbuster
Will Smith has spent enough time in
Hollywood to know that spoiling the
ending of a film before it comes out is
a Surefire way to ruin it for an
audience but in 2007 he did just that at
a news conference while talking about
his film I Am Legend as Smith began
rambling about the film co-producer and
co-screenwriter Akiva goldsmen realized
that he had gone too far and yelled
don't give away the ending but it was
too late and Smith had already crossed
the line the journalist present were
instructed not to report on the ending
of the film so thankfully they were able
to do damage control since I Am Legend
was based on a novel of the same name
that had already been adapted multiple
times Smith might have figured that
being loose-slipped about the details
wasn't a big deal after all plenty of
people had already read the book so
there weren't really any secrets to keep
right well not quite the screenwriters
completely changed the ending of the
film so ideally it was supposed to be a
surprise for everyone
with the franchise as huge as Star Wars
spoilers are bound to get out every once
in a while at the 2016 Star Wars
celebration in London jiong Wen who
played baze Malibus in the then upcoming
Rogue one a Star Wars story answered a
question about his own character he's
started off by saying that he couldn't
say much about his own fate but then he
proceeded to tell everyone in attendance
that Donnie Yen's character shiru and
way was gonna die and
when this guy dead
I do something better luckily panel MC
Gwendolyn Christie came to the rescue
and managed to stop Wen from giving
anything else away while he did stick to
his promise about keeping his own
characters fade a secret he did spoil
another one whoops it seems like he was
so eager to deflect the attention from
himself that he said a little too much
in 2009 Rachel McAdams starred in the
film The Time Traveler's Wife which was
based on the novel of the same name
McAdams could perhaps be forgiven for
assuming that the target audience for
the adaptation was already familiar with
the book of course the plot of any film
that involves time travel will almost
definitely include some trippy twists
and turns and that was the case with The
Time Traveler's Wife but those twists
aren't nearly as interesting when you
know it's coming in advance McAdams
began revealing major plot twists during
a 2009 interview with Jon Stewart on The
Daily Show he goes forward as far as his
own death
when she realized she had said too much
she didn't try to backtrack instead it
just seemed like she figured she might
as well run with it and keep talking
Stuart joked that he still couldn't wait
to see the film but after watching that
interview you really wouldn't need to
buy a ticket but obviously that's not
the plot laughs
[Applause]
Gwyneth Paltrow has always had trouble
holding back when it comes to spoilers
throughout her time playing Pepper Potts
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe She has
been known to let key details slip
before the premieres before the release
of Avengers end game she revealed a
major detail about Tony Stark and Pepper
Potts lives after the tragic events of
Avengers Infinity war and in doing so
she gave away a lot more than she
probably realized in an interview for
the official Infinity War magazine
Paltrow was asked about Pepper's
relationship with Tony she answered
pepper and Tony have had a real long
journey together she obviously starts as
his dutiful assistant and then the
relationship evolves and now this decade
later they're married and they have a
child
[Music]
yeah that last part was a big spoiler
for fans eagerly awaiting end game at
the time pepper and Tony were a Galaxy
apart following the events of Avengers
Infinity war and had only briefly talked
about having children so you've woke up
and not trip we were
expecting yeah yes now fans had no idea
they would be reunited and would have a
child after the time Jump and end game
what's most surprising is that the
official magazine printed the quote in
the first place
Michael Keaton dropped the mother of all
spoilers while promoting Tim Burton's
1989 Batman film during an interview
with David Letterman the two started
delving into Batman's origin story and
his connection with the Joker in the
midst of their conversation Keaton
seemingly forgot that the audience was
there for a second because he got a bit
carried away describing the plot
eyewitness Batman Bruce Wayne Witnesses
the uh the murder of his parents when
he's a kid and the Joker had done that
yeah but he doesn't know it till later I
actually kind of blowing the plot here
this of course was not an element of
existing Batman mythology invented as a
plot twist for the 89 film needless to
say this was a shock for both Letterman
and his audience but by that point the
damage had been done and the audience
was probably a little disappointed
fortunately the spoiler clearly didn't
affect the success of the film which
went on to make 411 million dollars
worldwide revitalized the comic industry
and helped Divine superhero movies as we
know them for some reason it seems
exceptionally difficult for the cast of
superhero films to keep quiet about key
plot points just look at Jason momoa's
slip up on The Late Late Show with James
Corden while promoting their new film
Aquaman Mamo and his co-star Yaya Abdul
Mateen II made an appearance on the show
and they let the audience in on a few
things they weren't really supposed to
know Momoa started talking about the
relationship between their two
characters and had a slip of the tongue
but then there's a whole emotional scene
with him and his father looks like kill
his dad oh
Momoa went on to joke that this is why
he always has Abdul Mateen answer the
questions maybe if he'd been in
character as Aquaman he'd have been more
tight-lipped about the plot something
something trident
see that's better
the ending of Avengers Infinity war was
gut-wrenching for Marvel fans when
Thanos snapped his fingers half of all
life in the universe disappeared but if
you caught a particular Good Morning
America interview with Don Cheadle and
Mark Ruffalo that aired almost a year
before the movie came out you might have
seen it coming wait till you see this
next one everybody died
not everybody no
is that it's true that Ruffalo wasn't
too specific with the spoiler so it
didn't seem too memorable at the time
but some fans probably did start to
suspect that depressing finale there's
no doubt that some of them fully
expected many of the Avengers to perish
of course having some time to steal
yourself emotionally might have made it
easier to accept your favorite
character's demise so maybe
thanked Mark Ruffalo Margie better than
Holland but that
that I taught Tom Holland
Tom Holland is the Undisputed king of
Marvel movie spoilers the actor has
dropped so many spoilers during
interviews that at this point it's
become a running joke but Holland is so
enthusiastic and endearing that it's
hard to feel annoyed at him for his
habit of letting spoilers slip before a
screening of Avengers Infinity war in
Los Angeles Holland made an appearance
and shouted I'm alive when the audience
seemed confused pollen's mistake slowly
dawned on him he was under the
impression that they had just seen the
film and knew his character would die
but it hadn't started yet whoops
Jiang Wen might have spoiled the fate of
one character in Rogue one but many
years before that David prowse ruined
the biggest plot twist in Star Wars
history when The Man Behind Darth
Vader's mask was interviewed about The
Empire Strikes Back In 1978 two years
before it was even released he openly
shared one of the most shocking moments
in any of the Star Wars films browse was
at a fan meet up when he dropped a bomb
regarding Luke Skywalker and Darth
Vader's relationship saying father can't
kill Sun Sun can't kill father
thankfully his reveal was only printed
in a single local newspaper article and
clearly not many people read the
original article because the vast
majority of fans were still totally
caught off guard
if you don't recognize the name Tyler
Nelson there's a reason for that he put
a stop to his acting career when it had
barely begun Nelson was cast as an extra
in Indiana Jones and the kingdom of the
Crystal Skull and naturally he was over
the moon about the opportunity to be a
part of an Indiana Jones film his role
was apparently to play a Russian dancing
after Indy was captured his involvement
got some attention in his hometown and a
local newspaper interviewed him to get
the scoop on the film but instead of
Simply sticking to the story of how he
ended up on set he started revealing the
entire plot of the film he might as well
have handed the reporter a script he
completely violated his non-disclosure
agreement and as a result he faced some
serious consequences once word got back
to the studio that Nelson had blabbed
Steven Spielberg's spokesman Marvin Levy
commented who knows whether that
particular person will ever work in this
town again Nelson was properly cut from
the film and his mistake appears to have
cost him a future in acting Spider-Man
no way home features several returning
actors from prior films in the franchise
including Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield as returning Spider-Man are you
okay oh my back just kind of
stiff from all the swinging I guess
while Marvel's attempts at keeping a lid
on the film's biggest comebacks were
always going to be tough considering how
many people were involved Alfred Molina
did them no favors the returning Doctor
Octopus actress filled the beans more
than a year before the film's release
the rumor started when Molina was
spotted on the set of the production and
the question came up as to his
involvement during an interview with
variety assuming that published reports
of his appearance had already made it
official the actor wasn't shy about it
he said when we were shooting it we were
all under orders not to talk about it
because it was supposed to be some great
big secret but you know it's all over
the internet I actually described myself
as the worst kept secret in Hollywood
up here he's up there it's the guy from
The Bridge a year after the film's
release though Molina told the radio
times that the studio was pretty miffed
that he confirmed his appearance he said
Kevin feige was on a red carpet
somewhere and someone asked him about
some Marvel movie and apparently he got
a bit snippy and turned around and said
ask Alfred Molina so I got into a little
bit of hot water
the Star Wars prequel trilogy was among
the first major movie series to be
produced in the era of Internet spoilers
as fan communities popped up in the mid
to late 90s it became harder and harder
to prevent plot leaks from reaching the
masses but while lucasfilms surely took
security seriously to prevent spoilers
they couldn't stop one of their own
Stars Samuel L Jackson from giving away
his own character's fate Jackson played
the lightsaber-wielding warrior Mace
Windu in the trilogy he was also one of
the biggest actors involved in the
trilogy and was always being asked about
his part in the films and in one
particularly revealing interview with
now playing magazine he talked a little
bit too much when asked about what part
his character had to play in the third
prequel Jackson bluntly told the
magazine dying yeah like all the rest of
the Jedi I can't tell you the specifics
but yeah it's an awesome death so the
prophecy says admittedly most fans
probably knew this was likely given the
backstory established in earlier films
but it was a startling admission from an
otherwise tight-lipped production and
sent fans into a frenzy
when you're a big Blockbuster movie is
based on a well-loved and widely read
comic book Universe it might be hard to
keep all of the story a secret the
movie's biggest plot points might be
common knowledge among comic book
readers but that doesn't mean wider
audiences know what's coming such was
the case for X-Men apocalypse the third
film in the relaunch franchise fan
favorite Peter maximoff AKA Quicksilver
returns from the previous film and one
of the major twists is the Revelation
that he's the son of long time X-Men
villain Magneto the fact that comic fans
might have already guessed are you gonna
tell him
my
my one day unfortunately actor Evan
Peters just couldn't keep the secret for
everyone else while talking to Joe Blow
about his character's place in the film
he said I have learned that Magneto is
my father at this point he knows who he
is now so he is trying to find him he's
been searching for him it's been 10
years and he hasn't found him and then
something happens ultimately of course
X-Men apocalypse wasn't the popular
acclaimed Blockbuster that the previous
films had been and the spoiled
Revelation wasn't something that wound
up ruining the movie thankfully though
Peters remained much more tight-lipped
when it came to his return in Marvel's
One Division in 2021.
you might not expect the modest
low-budget character drama about a man
and his dog to be the subject of a major
spoiler discussion but here we are
starring Channing Tatum the 2022 film
dog was inspired by the actor's own life
and a road trip he took with his dying
dog in 2018. the film doesn't include
any truly dramatic plot twists stunning
Revelations or major mind benders in
fact it's a fairly light-hearted
family-friendly tale with a happy ending
but that's exactly why Tatum himself
gave away the ending before it released
in a kind of reverse spoiler Tatum
talked about what didn't happen in the
movie and it wasn't a mistake or slip up
in fact it was in an attempt to attract
more people to the film considering the
history of animal movies like The Call
of the Wild and Marley and me both were
advertised as upbeat family films and
end as tear jerkers as a result Tatum
wanted to assure audiences that dog
would not conclude with the depressing
or morose ending it's a good ending so
everyone knows
when it comes to tragic character deaths
few can top the emotional tour to force
that audiences endure in Logan the third
solo film for Wolverine played by Hugh
Jackman his ninth appearance in the role
it was highly publicized as the last
time Jackman would wield the adamantium
claws and the Rumor Mill is spinning
that Logan wouldn't survive the events
of the movie Very Loosely adapted from
the Epic comic book mini-series Old Man
Logan the film might not have killed off
its hero had it stuck closer to its
source material but in the end with
Jackman insistent on retiring the role
it indeed ends with the death of the
title character
oh this is
but while many were expecting Logan's
demise it most assuredly was not a
certainty going into the release of the
film that is not until Jackman himself
decided to say it rather plainly in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly the
interview was published the day after
the film's release but for everyone who
couldn't make it to the premiere it was
a huge spoiler Jackman told ew as soon
as I saw the script I got it Logan is
someone who's most scared of intimacy
and so he wants to be alone and do
things for himself the idea that in the
end he must give his life to save
someone else I thought that was really
powerful
Wireless casting was announced all the
way back in 2007 Dwayne The Rock Johnson
finally starred as the titular anti-hero
in Black Adam when it was released in
2022 though it lacks Shazam the heroes
whose comic books originally spawned
Black Adam back in the 1940s the film
still had plenty of surprises this
includes the Justice Society of America
an iconic superhero team featuring
Heroes like Dr Fate and Hawkman but it
also included a jaw-dropping
post-credits scene that had to be seen
to be believed this Henry Cavill
reprized his role as the Man of Steel in
a sequence that set up a future Clash of
Titans the only problem was the rock
himself had already spoiled the scene in
the days leading up to the film while
promoting the movie on the red carpet of
the film's world premiere more than a
week before its wide release Johnson
talked to Entertainment Weekly and
decided to let the cat out of the bag
when asked about the presence of
Superman in the film we've all been
fighting for this moment so I will say
this
welcome home though he didn't say it
explicitly Entertainment Weekly knew
exactly what he was saying and tweeted
out the clip with the announcement that
Henry Cavill had returned to Superman
and was back in the dceu as we all know
now of course that didn't last
Star Wars Revenge of the Sith wasn't the
last major Blockbuster movie that Samuel
L Jackson wound up spoiling in his
effort to promote his next big flick
nearly 15 years later in 2019 Jackson
starred in Captain Marvel a prequel to
The MCU set in the 1990s in addition to
introducing Cosmic hero Carol Danvers it
shed new light on the history of
Jackson's Nick Fury digitally de-aged
Jackson was a major part of the story
which revealed Fury's first meeting with
a superhero and how he conceived of the
Avengers Initiative but that wasn't all
in one of the most fun Revelations was
spoiled by Jackson himself across two
separate interviews before the movie
even released it all started while
Jackson was speaking with Entertainment
Tonight in January of 2019. he
recklessly revealed that the film would
tell the story behind Fury's famous
eyepatch but didn't elaborate on how
he'd lose it that detail would come
while he was being interviewed for the
playlist just days before the film
landed in theaters though it may not
have been entirely his fault having seen
the film ahead of its official release
the interviewer directly addressed how
he lost the eye while Jackson went right
along and talked about it even
addressing rumors that he doesn't like
cats an allegation he denied I'm gonna
keep giving him all the logs and hugs
that he needs at the time of its rollout
one of the biggest stars in phase one of
the MCU was Natalie Portman in 2011's
Thor the A-list actor had just won an
Oscar earlier that year and starred
opposite Chris Hemsworth as Jane Foster
a scientist who discovers the Asgardian
Prince after he's banished to Earth but
following a bad experience on the sequel
Thor the Dark World Ortman swore off
working for Marvel some years later the
prospect of working with the director
taika waititi was enough to lure her
back to the MCU for Thor love and
thunder but in her excitement she also
spoiled a major plot twist before the
movie came out while it was well known
thanks to trailers that her character
Jane Foster would be given the powers of
Thor what audiences who weren't comic
readers probably didn't see coming was
that Foster is stricken with terminal
cancer and your powers allow her to
Stave off her own death unfortunately
Portman went a little too far in talking
about all that while speaking with
inducing times while promoting the film
a month early she's new at it and also
keeps reverting to human form so there's
kind of danger always that like it might
be her last moment getting to experience
that but apparently Portman realized her
snafu because she immediately
acknowledged the cardinal sin she just
committed and added I don't know that
might be that might be a big spoiler
sorry when it was announced that King
the Conqueror would be the villain of
the third Ant-Man film speculation went
into overdrive on what the film might be
about while Rudd remained cagey on the
details but his co-star Evangeline Lilly
let the excitement of her return get the
better of her eager to share her prep
work on the film ahead of the movie's
production the actor took to social
media posting images for her Legions of
followers what they briefly saw was the
front cover of the film's screenplay and
while it wasn't enough to reveal any of
the script's secrets who she tagged gave
the game away because in addition to
tagging her known co-stars she also
curiously tagged Corey Stahl the actor
who had co-starred in the first film in
the series as the villain yellowjacket
had not been officially announced as a
member of the cast and when the media
got wind of her post the rumor mill
immediately fired up her Rush deletion
of the post only added fuel to the fire
as many suspected stole did wind up
returning in the threequel thankfully
though Lily never let slip that his
character had been transformed into the
comic book villain Modoc a secret that
the studio is clearly saving for the
film's release
foreign
[Music]